ah let's get right into it I think I the
q''-word had just left my mouth on the
pre-show and then they just started the
show oh my god quake is back quake is
that quake alright looks awesome quake
champions that's what they're calling us
yeah I for a like a hot second I was
real worried they made a quake MOBA that
would the champion words got like a
bunch of weight on it yeah but they
showed off what was I guess a you know
just Reno pre-render crossing situation
which showed off it was really weird
because they had like a bunch of
characters that looked like they'd like
a strong looking dude who looked like
gives that equate to they had a sort of
futuristic version of what looked like
Sarge who was like the main character
and quake three main skin but they
didn't really show off all that much it
was just kind of a bunch of different
unit what it looked like was kind of
like different characters with unique
abilities which is not what quake was a
batch but and who knows tomorrow what
did you think it is I think it looks I
thought was really interesting like they
clearly it's taking what we expect from
a classic quake type game and trying to
introduce more modern conventions you
know modern shooters are all about
unique defined a class based or whatever
year's class based like people have a
tend to shy away from calling it
class-based then they instead say like
ability based or they build characters
with unique styles right and I've let
people just play to those classes
without using a boring buzzword like
class base and like what we're looking
at here is you can see what looks like a
lightning gun I mean that's straight up
a quake rocket launcher there see that
green one kind of looks like a rail
gunshot even though they be a bit on the
fat side and yeah I'm sure like I am
they're just wanting to go to quakecon
because they said yo we're making a new
quake game will show it off for quakecon
because it's called quakecon and we
haven't shown a quake there for a while
and yeah what do you think like yeah it
looks awesome I mean like just the
fast-paced gameplay like I mean doom
like kind of you've been talking about
doing a lot lately and single player was
great but also do multiplayer leaves me
wanting more yeah and this seems like
this that could fill the gap like it
totally makes sense now yeah why they
didn't do an arena
uterine do yeah because they're like
straight up doing it here in quick I
guess yeah really interesting like
different abilities there there was sort
of like a weird blink mechanic one of
them had almost like I mean it's funny
right everything we talk about now is
over watch a mobile that's like the
touchstone we have him work rice so like
widow-makers like I you know wall
hacking basically there was a character
who had some of the knife out there I
mean there was pop there was pickups as
well there was somebody picking up
something that looked a little bit like
quad damage so yeah I think the
interesting thing there was like a focus
on they said two things that kind of
caught my attention one right it's gonna
run out 120 Hertz with unkept frame rate
yeah which means you can play to your
eyes bleed it whatever the other thing
you said like they they specifically
name-checked like not new people yes
they dating it like easy to get into
yeah overcomplicating I worried me a bit
yeah which is kind of like what does
that mean I mean in on the one hand a
first person shooter multiplayer
experience in the style of the classic
quake game and simple enough for that
for the newcomer to take care of like
very harder to get in to a modern call
of duty than it is to like quick one or
two like exact totally yeah even like 35
in five to ten minutes for sure on the
other hand it could mean that they're
trying to really let simplify it in a
way that's you know different because
they are introducing abilities and stuff
like that yeah well it looks like it
anyway so I I just want to watch this
trailer over and over again I'm like
break it down figure out who's who and
what's wat because there's so much slow
like that guy looks a little bit like
Sarge to me and we'll see how this guy
looks like a strong I don't know but
have to wait and see yeah yeah well I
guess we'll find out soon enough or
quakecon later this year some more about
it at the final piece about this
tomorrow you said saber interactive
we're working on this yeah it looks like
saber interactive who developed time
shift and have since done the halo
anniversary edition yes are working on
this game in some capacity alongside its
software which I mean saber have done
good work in the past time shift
notwithstanding well hallo master chief
collection online connectability non
sarà in terms of like creating you know
first person she experiences they're
pretty good at putting that stuff
together
hmm as long as its software can you know
fill in the cracks which they tend to
kind of leave around it should be a good
experience yeah I also means because it
is saber interactive with its software
it means battlecry Studios rice appear
at all which is nothing from battle cry
studios at all today who knows whether
they exist anymore yeah we had a week
thought maybe they could be contributing
to another project maybe they're doing
that on other stuff quietly but there
was no mention about cry studios at all
about the game which means it might have
just been without to say a wig it's got
this real deep quake lure that guy
couldn't look like anarchy who is the
guy who goes around on a hoverboard and
quake three all right kind of look like
an icky a bit maybe that's an icky all
right mmm that was like the puncture
hold open brought the tactic text and
then it was just quick boom boom yeah so
not rocket launcher and I was like no
perfect all right what does it do it
again